mes semis de l'éducation nationale
plutôt latin ou grec peut-être arts
plastiques langue des signes ou encore
EPS les options sont plus ou moins
variées selon les lycées qu'ils soient
littéraires scientifiques ou
technologiques l'école de la République
offre de nombreux choix à nos élèves
mais certainement pas celui de la
laïcité l'article 10 de la Déclaration
des Droits de l'Homme et du Citoyen
proclame que nul ne doit être inquiété
pour ses opinions même religieuses
pourvu que leur manifestation ne
troublent pas la loi or aujourd'hui
l'ordre public semble compromis par la
montée concomitante du communautarisme
et de l'intégrisme qui n'épargne pas les
écoles de notre pays les exemples
récents sont nombreux comme celui du
lycée de Langevin de La Seyne-sur-Mer 4
élèves ont souhaité figurer sur la photo
de classe en tenue traditionnelle
islamique refusant de se plier aux
consignes de leur professeur sous
prétexte que chaque personne devrait
venir comme elle le souhaite au lycée
non la laïcité conquise dans le sang et
les larmes à rebours du pouvoir
politique dit que les religions
s’octroyées n’est pas une option oui la
laïcité incarne cette impartialité cette
neutralité de l'État comme cadre qui
permet d'accueillir toutes les personnes
quel que soit leur convictions ne pas
endoctriner ne pas faire de prosélytisme
telle est la loi du 15 mars 2004 porté
par le président Jacques Chirac et
François Baroin une avancée courageuse
qui interdit aux élèves le port de signe
religieux
ostensible dans les établissements
publics ce port
ostentatoire ne veut aucun bien ni à
l'école ni à la République et de
nombreux élèves aujourd'hui tentent de
se prévaloir de leur foi pour se
soustraire aux règles communes
quand comprendrez-vous qu'il s'agit là
d'une arme contre la laïcité monsieur le
ministre l'école et des emparée face aux
vêtements religieux nos professeurs en
première ligne sont contraint à
l'autocensure par peur des intérêts
craintes de stigmatiser le religieux
s'est immédié dans la vie
professionnelle des enseignants monsieur
le ministre allez vous faire preuve de
transparence quant aux chiffres sur les
nombreux cas d'atteinte à la laïcité
dans nos écoles où allez-vous continuer
sur la politique du pas de vague